bien chers amis nous voici à nouveau
raynaud réunies pour une nouvelle table
ronde cet après midi à guidel une table
ronde sur la thématique de comment
réduire aujourd'hui la fracture et où
les fractures territoriales
en france avec plusieurs invités de
marque alors les invités maison que vous
connaissez déjà bien sûr jacqueline
gourault notre ministre en charge de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
marc fesneau notre ministre en charge
des relations avec le parlement et de la
participation citoyenne
frédéric dabi donc qui est directeur
général
de l'ipsos le l'ifop pardon excusez moi
ça commence bien
de l'ifop la faute de l'ifop et qui
vient de publier deux co publié un livre
très intéressant sur la fracture
notamment sur la jeunesse mais
aujourd'hui nous allons plutôt parler de
fracture territoriale même si on aura
des passerelles avec ce qui se passe
avec la jeunesse nous avons beau scoop
du monde qui est un jeune étudiant qui
vient de finir son année d'étude et qui
va nous raconter il a vécu une
expérience très intéressante il a
sillonné la france pour justement aller
voir ce qui se passait sur le territoire
en terme de fracture mais on verra
l'étude s'est beaucoup élargi et puis
internet qui est une élue locale du
mouvement élu de normand dire de l'eure
qui a plusieurs casquettes et qui
notamment travaille beaucoup également
sur la problématique de l'habitat etc
sur ses différentes casquettes pas là
donc pour commencer peut-être avec
frédéric dabi donc un retour sur comment
qualifierez ton aujourd'hui les
différentes fractures par rapport aux
études que vous que vous conduit ou que
tu conduis ce qu'on me dit qu on se
tutoyait citoyens voilà donc quelles
sont les différentes fractures comme on
peut les qualifier aujourd'hui par
rapport à ce que tu as pu observer dans
la société et quels sont les enjeux qui
sont devant nous merci beaucoup pour
jour à toutes et tous merci au modem
pour son invitation on n'est pas dans
des lieux officiels ou en
costard-cravate donc on peut être
décontracté pour autant essayer de dire
des trucs sérieux effectivement l'ifop
travaille énormément sur la question de
fracture on a réalisé quelques enquêtes
approfondie avant et après le mouvement
des gilet jaune parce que bien sûr ce
qui a été le moteur des gilets jaunes ça
a été un sentiment d'injustice envers
territoriale de fracture qui avait
intégré aussi bien l'accès aux services
publics la mobilité les déserts médicaux
l'accès aux soins je rappellerai que la
santé dans toutes nos enquêtes est la
première préoccupation des français mais
ça préexistait au coville sait depuis
2010 9 quand ce qu vide n'existait pas
que la santé était devenue la première
préoccupation alors sur ses fractures
avait atterri derrière on peut dire
beaucoup de choses mais au coeur de ces
fractures quand je vois toutes nos
enquêtes quantitatives qualitatives ou
des français expriment spontanément se
niche si je peux dire la question de la
relation des habitants la relation des
citoyens à l'état à la sphère étatique
ce n'est pas anodin dans notre pays où
on sait qu'il ya une attente très forte
vis-à-vis de l'état du politique la
magie du politique la promesse du
politique s'est transformée peser sur le
cours des choses changer la vie comme un
vieux slogan socialiste puis
mitterrandien la fin des années 70 et
une petite fête parenthèses ce qui
allait nous a beaucoup inquiété ce qui
peut inquiéter tout citoyen à l'issue de
ce cycle électoral départemental
régional c'est que l'abstention il ya eu
toute une série de raisons à cette
abstention historique mais notamment
chez les jeunes et je le montre dans le
livre faisait gentiment cité il ya un
sentiment désormais de vanité
d'inutilité du vote voter ça ne sert
plus à rien car voter ne sert plus à
changer la vie c'est un défi pour tous
les politiques pour pouvoir faire pour
casser cette équation donc la relation
des habitants des citoyens à l'état on
le trouve dans une sorte de corrélation
une question qu'on pose historiquement
depuis une vingtaine d'années à l'ifop
aux habitants de toute commune de france
seat ont le sentiment de bénéficier de
l'action des services publics pour eux
et dans leur commune on a un rapport qui
est plutôt intéressant 64% des français
disent oui on a un gros tiers qui dit
non ça s'est réduit depuis la crise du
coc vite parce que le manque que l'on
puisse dire c'est glauque où le quoi
qu'il en coûte l'état a été extrêmement
présent même s'il n'a pas échappé à des
critiques al'inverse d'acteur
locaux et c'est vrai que quand on a ce
gros tiers de français qui nous disent
je ne bénéficie pas de l'action des de
l'état dans ma commune c'est une
minorité mais ça fait beaucoup de monde
dans une logique d'extrapolation et bien
sûr c'est plus dans les petites villes
que dans les métropoles c'est beaucoup
plus dans les communes rurales
que dans les villes moyennes et c'est
beaucoup plus dans les banlieues
populaires que dans les banlieues aisées
et une fois que ces français ont le
sentiment de pas de ne pas bénéficier de
l'action des avis publics l'action de
l'état se met en marche une sorte en
marche sans aucun jugement une sorte de
mécanique infernale sur le plan
individuel un sentiment d'abandon
d'isolement un sentiment de relégation
ça a été le moteur des gilet jaune j'ai
travaillé sur la seine-et-marne où il ya
la seine et marne du rer où on a accès à
beaucoup de services publics on est à
quelques minutes si je puis dire de
paris et puis la seine-et-marne du train
ou pour faire paris provins paris l'ont
ville j'ai pas si vous y êtes allé voir
ce qu on met plus de temps que pour
faire paris lille ou paris reims et on
se sent tout à fait isolé sur le plan
individuel c'est ce sentiment
d'isolement et sur le plan collectif
c'est bien sur le déclin l'image d'un
âge d'or qu'on a pour son déclin pour
pour sa ville pour son département une
sorte de paradis perdu et si je puis
dire ça match beaucoup en ce en ce
moment on est à 6 mois et 10 jours je
crois du scrutin présidentiel du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle et ce
qui me frappe c'est que jamais l'idée
que le pays est en déclin a été aussi
fortement partagé par les français donc
déclin locale est également déclin du
pays maintenant pour vous répondre et ne
pas dépasser les 5 minutes quand on
regarde les fractures que les français
mettent le plus en avant c'est bien sûr
des fractures protéiforme est vraiment
une fois de plus il ya l'idée d'un d'une
absence de bénéfice des services publics
c'était une enquête faite en 2019 pour
le groupe a l'air de l'assemblée fête
nationale 34% des français seulement
considéré de vivre dans un territoire
délaissé par les services publics ça
monte à 38 dans les villes périphériques
et à 56 dans des communes rurales et
puis quand on dit
services publics les français ce terme
n'a pas peut-être la même connotation
qu'on peut avoir ici autour de cette
table service public il ya une vision
extrêmement extensive le service public
c'est le service au public
par exemple une banque s'est vu comme un
service public dans le sens où il ya une
frustration même s'il ya des progrès qui
ont été faits pour aller retirer un dab
20 ou 50 euros parfois il ya une
vingtaine et une trentaine de kilomètres
à faire et donc les commerces la
supérette le café dans le petit village
est vu comme un service public quand on
demande aux français est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec la phrase je vis dans
un territoire où les commerces de
proximité se font de plus en plus rares
ils sont 57% à dire oui c'était en 2019
et bien sûr c'est archi minoritaire dans
les grandes métropoles et ça monte à 82%
dans les zones rurales donc service
public service au public au sens large
je noterai que sur cette question dans
notre baromètre de rentrer sur les
sujets prioritaires ça a pris 9 points
la question de la sauvegarde des
services publics par rapport à septembre
2020 et que c'est un sujet qui est de
moins en moins clivé entre la gauche et
la droite à une époque il y avait un
discours un peu
comment dire
totémique c'est-à-dire à gauche plus de
service public à droite il en faut moins
parce que y apprennent de rentabilité de
productivité ce discours a très
largement vécu autres fractures qu'on
voit dans nos enquêtes une fracture et à
l'accès à l'emploi il est de plus en
plus difficile de trouver un emploi dans
ma commune ou dans des communes en
verrine environnantes que dans le reste
du pays là aussi même logique entre
métropole et communes rurales et france
périphérique et puis bien sûr et c'est
pour ça que je faisais tout à leur faire
référence à la question de la santé qui
a largement préexisté à la crise duco
vide la question de l'accès aux soins
qui est le public de plus en plus forte
difficile à l'endroit où je vis alors ça
peut paraître un petit peu comment dire
systématique et ça prend pas en compte
toute une série de fides puisque moi je
suis parfois un peu agacé sur toute une
série d'idées reçues que des enquêtes
qualitatives bat en brèche l'idée de
métropole choyé où tout va très bien
deux communes rurales où c'est
absolument la catastrophe on vient de
faire vient de refaire la grande enquête
que qu'on avait présentée avec jacques
mézard en 2017 sur les pour
l'association des familles rurales on
voit un bonheur rural on voit une
attractivité du monde rural et on voit
également que dans ce contexte de
fracture territoriale mais je vais pas
en parler ici sera peut-être l'objet de
notre débat il ya un objet une type 1
type de territoire qui montent en flèche
en termes d'attractivité d'intérêt et de
bouquets de services publics ce sont les
villes moyennes voilà merci merci
beaucoup frédérique allard avant de
poursuivre on m'indique qu'il ya un
véhicule qui gêne une ce milieu secours
une issue de secours c'est une fiat tipo
avait 5 121 kg donc il faudrait bouger
le véhicule s'il vous plaît parce que
c'est un accès qui est gênant de rien
chez un ami finalement quand donc dans
ce que tu disais frédéric est ce que tu
a observé un glissement entre une
fracture urbaine rurale et une fracture
donc on pouvait considérer a vendu par
rapport aux quartiers on échange et un
peu là-dessus total est ce qu'il ya un
glissement
sur les quartiers oui alors c'est vrai
qu'on a vu
toujours un sentiment
fait appartenance très fort vis-à-vis de
sa ville mais dans les endroits les plus
en difficulté qui bénéficie de plus de
la politique de la ville on a eu une
substitution de l'attachement à sa ville
pour un attachement à son quartier alors
que dans les villes moyennes c'est ça
qui est très intéressant il ya une
vision assez globalisante et homogène
d'accord merci alors bosco toi tu nous a
fait une petite aventure cet été à la
fin de tes études donc tu vas nous
expliquer un peu ça l'objet de ton sujet
d'étude qui est très intéressant et qui
au départ avait pour objet de traiter
donc les répercussions de la crise qu
vide et puis finalement au fil des
rencontres que tu as pu faire sur le
territoire donc le sujet c'était largy
alors elle raconte nous un peu ton
aventure oui donc bonjour à toutes et à
tous et merci aux équipes du modem pour
leur invitation à partager à vous
présenter mon projet à portée de roues
donc en deux mots je suis parti à la fin
de mes études en avril dernier pour un
voyage de cinq mois à travers toute la
france le but c'était de passer en fait
par les 96 départements de france
métropolitaine donc c'est un itinéraire
de un peu plus de dix mille kilomètres
voilà qui m'a pris un peu de temps et le
but c'était d'aller rencontrer dans
chaque département un ou plusieurs
responsables politiques élus locaux élus
nationaux représentant de l'état
techniciens pour discuter effectivement
oui du rôle des collectivités dans le
rebond social et économique posco vide
mais des sujets un peu plus larges comme
baby le les relations entre les
collectivités et l'état le rôle des
collectivités dans la transition
écologique dans l'engagement citoyen
voilà donc ces discussions assez libre
assez assez générales qui ont qui m'ont
permis de réfléchir à une grande variété
de sujets
et je me suis concentré effectivement
sur le côté très hétérogène qu'on a en
france un peu sur tous les plans quand
on parle de fracture tectoy je pense
qu'il faut vraiment garde en mémoire le
fait que en fait la france c'est un pays
un territoire qui est d'une
hétérogénéité assez dingue c'est pour ça
que j'étais assez content de faire ce
voyage à vélo je me suis bien rendu
compte mes jambes sont bien rendus
compte aussi
qu'il y avait voilà que dans une table
200 kilomètres je pouvais traversé trois
quatre cinq régions naturelles
différentes voilà avec en passant des
paysages de bocage et le paysage de
plaines des paysages de deux rivaux de
montagne bien sûr faisait moins d relief
et que en fait chaque département ils
ont beau avoir 200 ans une vraie
légitimité dans le coeur des gens ça n'a
jamais gommer les régions naturelles qui
préexistait les régions historiques qui
préexistait et que voilà on peut se
retrouver dans le département dont la
saône et loire dans le sud bourgogne qui
a qui est coupée entre la brest qui est
totalement plate l'autunois qui est en
fait contre les contreforts du morvan le
charolais qui dépensent géologiquement
du massif central le châlonnais le
mâconnais des sillons du creusot voilà
donc faut garder ça en tête je pense et
je pense que c'est aussi déterminant
pour tout ce qui est laid ce que tout ce
que sont les hétérogénéités économique
on peut lier ça à la fois à la structure
sectorielle donc des zones d'emploi donc
qui sont des regroupements des
territoires au tour de ville centre
j'ai bien je me suis pas rendu compte
pendant ce
trajet que les territoires avaient été
plus ou moins sinistré par par la crise
fait j'ai fait mon mémoire de fin de fin
d'étude sous la direction de jean noël
barrot qui sur justement l'hétérogénéité
territoriale de la crise économique
lié à la co lead et c'est vrai qu'a
effectivement voilà quand je me suis
rendu par exemple à tarbes j'ai
rencontré mon interlocuteur kim avant de
préciser que la zone d'emploi de tarbes
et de lourdes ça dépend un des
pèlerinages dans tourisme international
avec lourdes et deux de l'industrie
aéronautique donc ces mots c'était hors
construit sur un champ de ruines de même
en plus des structures sectorielles il
faut souligner que les mesures
sanitaires ont eu des effets plus ou
moins fort les territoires montagnards
notamment je pense aux briançonnais
quand je suis passé dans les
hautes-alpes
85 90 % des emplois dépendent du
tourisme des monts talent de monter
mécanique et donc c'est si quelque chose
à prendre en compte et cette
hétérogénéité là se retrouve aussi dans
les les dernières réformes territoriales
et les institutions en fait je pense que
ça c'est important de garder en tête que
le chèque collectivités à sa singularité
et un rôle différent en fonction des
territoires et peut-être que les lois
map tam les lois de notre ont pas
forcément il ya eu des angles morts qui
ont pu avoir des mauvaises effet un peu
à tous les niveaux par exemple avec la
loi notre au niveau communal les
intercommunalités le seuil minimal pour
la formation du intercomités est passé
de 5000 habitants à 15000 donc en fait
mécaniquement il ya eu beaucoup de
fusion dans ta communauté pour respecter
ce seuil minimal
et donc ça a créé par fouad et des
exemples assez
compliqué je me suis rendu par un plan
mariage dans couserans j'ai rencontré le
président de la communauté de communes
couserans pyrénées qui à la tête d'une
communauté de communes qui rassemble 94
communes pour 30000 habitants avec un
fonctionnement très compliqué avec 120
élus communautaires pour les conseils
communautaires et un budget
d'investissements de 10 millions d'euros
donc qui ne répond pas forcément aux
besoins du territoire ce qu'on trouve au
niveau communal on retrouve aussi au
niveau départemental avec cette perte de
la compétence économique qui a eu des
effets parfois néfastes dans certains
territoires il ya eu du bon
effectivement de déléguer sa des régions
fort soit des intercomités forte mais
dans certains départements
il est conseil ont été contraints de
créer des agences d'attractivité des
sociétés d'économie mixte qui remplace
ce rôle des agences économiques pour
continuer à soutenir l'économie du
territoire
voilà par exemple le loir et cher dans
le région centre a créé une agence
d'astrid
à créer
non mais ça c'est intéressant parce que
ils ont pas évidemment ils sont restés
dans leur périmètre ils n'ont pas des
pluies n'ont pas pris la compétence
économique mais ça répondait aussi un
besoin de du fait que la région centre
val de loire à une agence
économique des peuples qui ne comptait
que deux équivalents temps plein dans le
loir et cher et donc c'est pour ça que
le le conseil départemental a souhaité
voilà mettre en place une agence
d'attractivité pas pour prendre ce rôle
là mais pour insister et attirer des
entreprises également sur son territoire
et enfin au niveau régional c'est
évidemment la fusion des régions qui a
eu c'est assez c'est assez particulier
moi quand je me suis rendu dans la
région dans l'ensemble des départements
en fait de région grand est il n'a pas
un de mes interlocuteurs qui me dit que
c'est une bonne chose cette fusion
région grand test parce que en fait
chaque département regarde dans une
direction différente entre les alsaciens
qui sont plus tournés vers l'allemagne à
l'astuce peut-être les les la marne plus
vers le bassin parisien la haute-marne
plus vers la bourgogne et à la moselle
peut-être plus vers le luxembourg aussi
donc ça c'est peut-être compliqué
fonctionné ainsi d'accord donc
territorialement si je comprends bien
des ajustements encore à faire pour
éviter de de contribuer à aggraver cette
fracture en tout cas ce sentiment de
fracture territoriale c'est ça moi je
pense que ce qu'il faut vraiment prendre
en compte c'est le la singularité de
chaque collectivité je pense que chaque
collectivité un rôle différent en
fonction de son ancrage géographique que
le conseil départemental n'a pas le même
rôle là où il ya beaucoup sur ben fort
où il ya une une métropole qui a
beaucoup de compétences et beaucoup de
moyens que dans des territoires ruraux
où finalement le conseil départemental
c'est un peu la seule collectivité qui
est doté d'une ingénierie territoriale
suffisante
ou la différenciation finalement pas
exactement ça fait partie des pistes je
pense qu'il faut approfondir je pense
vraiment que c'est une question clé en
termes de fracture territoriale
pour les les en fait pour l'élection
présidentielle à venir que que c'est un
marqueur d'identification pour les gens
qui vont être à rapprocher le pouvoir
des territoires il répond donc assez
assez cet été originalité donc sur tous
les plans géographique économique est en
fait un petit chez soi des
institutionnels d'accord merci pour cet
pour ce retour d'expérience et et pour
cette belle aventure que j'ai vécu et
que tu nous permet de connaître de
découvrir aujourd'hui
alors anne thérèse avec ta casquette
d'élu local puisque tu es adjoint au
maire à louviers également vice
présidente de l'agglomération et
conseillère départementale vice
présidente du département par rapport à
ce qui a été dit sur le rôle des
institutions
le rôle des différentes collectivités
comment tu vois aujourd'hui les selon
pertinent pour lutter contre la fracture
sociale est ce que tu as des pistes par
rapport à ses différentes casquettes à
nous expliquer lui ça certainement mais
peut-être juste d'une manière générale
dans un premier temps effectivement
frédéric l'a bien dit moscou on a parlé
il en a été le témoin pendant son tour
de france c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
de territoires qui peine à se projeter
en fait et qui vint dans cet avenir et
qui
ne font par manifestent leur inquiétude
et donc effectivement on parle de
fracture territoriale on a une petite et
un petit aperçu la d'après ce que
frédéric nous a dit du ressenti de nos
concitoyens
voilà moi je
je pense qu'il faut peut-être un moment
donné qu'on arrive à préciser exactement
de quoi ils veulent parler c'est vrai
qu'il ya des questions d'inégalité
d'accès d'inégalité des chances de
différences territoriales
à l'aube à l'aune pardon de la mesure du
pib c'est sûr qu'il ya de ces disparités
d'un territoire à l'autre d'une région à
l'autre d'une intercommunalité d'une
commune à l'autre parfois même d'un
quartier au sein d'une même ville donc
voilà on a en a je crois à une tendance
à opposer aujourd'hui à l'aune de ce cet
indicateur du pib les grandes agglos et
métropole qui sont supposés bénéficier
de la mondialisation et on en a très
bien parlé frédéric en a très bien parlé
et puis cette idée qu'on a des
périphéries abandonné moi je crois et
frédéric a dit aussi que la réalité est
évidemment plus nuancé et j'aimerais
quand même posé là
avant dire sans quoi je crois mais une
conviction forte qui est qu' on doit
aussi regarder ce qui est positif et
qu'en france on bénéficie néanmoins
d'une protection sociale très fort très
puissante dont on a tendance un peu
qu'on a tendance un peu à oublier avec
notamment enfin on est quand même le
pays qui consacre la part de son pib la
part de la plus importante de tous les
pays européens voilà on est les numéros
1 cette protection sociale et on a bien
vu là pendant la crise sanitaire que ça
avait eu une fonction d' amortisseur
très fort et même pendant les crises
économiques qui ont précédé c'est
important de leur dire quand même que ce
qu'on bénéficie de ce système de
protection et qu'on a bénéficié alors
après à un niveau différent selon les
époques mais d'un investissement public
étatique d'abord très puissant qui fait
que l'on bénéficie d'un
d'infrastructures dans l'ensemble de
notre pays alors évidemment avec des
niveaux qui sont pas toujours comparé à
mai quand même d'une manière générale
d'une infrastructure forte ce qui n'est
pas le cas de l'allemagne par exemple
qui a complètement sous investis
publiquement et qui aujourd'hui se
trouve confrontée à des défis est donc
plutôt que de parler de ses fractures
même si effectivement elle existe au
moins dans l'esprit de nos concitoyens
je pense qu'on
surtout à l'heure des transitions et des
transitions qui sont qui sont
démographique des transitions
économiques des transition
environnementale et qui constitue pour
nos territoires pour nos élus pour nos
habitants en fait des défis qui sont
absolument majeur et qu'effectivement
c'est on est on évolue dans un dans un
monde dans une dans un temps dans un
voilà dans une société qui est ultra
complexe et qu'il faut relever ces défis
alors louvier c'est une ville d'un peu
moins de dix neuf mille habitants dont
villes moyennes d'ailleurs on n'avait
pas si vous avez suivi ça dans la presse
mais on a fait l'objet d'un on a été une
étape dans un tourisme électorale d'un
candidat qui se lancent qui est venue la
semaine dernière à louviers samedi matin
et qui a qui s'est pas beaucoup
renseigné sur la ville qui n'a même pas
eu la courtoisie de d'annoncer sa venue
arnaud montebourg si vous n'aviez pas
suivi je le dit arnaud montebourg est
venu samedi dernier
non c'est pas lui qu'on a pensé
n'empêche que c'est lui qui est venu il
est il est tout de même candidat est qui
et qui donc n'a pas vu la courtoisie
d'avertir le maire et qui nous a fait
toute une diatribe sur les villes
moyennes et pauvres vie moyenne
totalement abandonnée c'est dans une
action
il voit là avec vraiment c'était très
triste on a pris le parti alors c'est
vrai qu'on a on a des difficultés donc
enfin on s'inscrit dans un territoire
plus large quelle intercommunalité
senneurs cent cinq mille habitants un
beau territoire d'industrie pour autant
à louviers c'est plus de 20% de
personnes qui vivent sous le taux de
pauvreté
et quand on fait les calculs ou
globalement sur l'ensemble du territoire
senneurs les trois quarts des habitants
qui vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté
n'habitent pas nos quartiers
prioritaires parce qu'on a évidemment
des quartiers prioritaires donc on voit
bien là c'est de cette disparité 7 cette
complexité du territoire à appréhender
moi j'ai le souvenir au début de mon
mandat de nicolas collin qui était venu
faire une conférence à louviers qui nous
avait dit ceci un territoire porteurs de
handicap évidemment que nous avons
beaucoup de handicaps à louviers sur le
territoire sénat c'est aussi un
territoire qui est hautement porteurs de
business et donc de solution est en fait
pour moi
si on alors évidemment mon échelon
pertinent puisque c'est de ça dont il
s'agit c'est l'intercommunalité mais
c'est un secret pour personne que je
suis aussi vice-présidente de la dcf
intercommunalités de france donc
l'association des lieux voilà donc j'y
crois beaucoup à cette intercommunalité
à cette coopération intercommunale qui
finalement à l'échelon territorial
pourrait être comparé aux coopérations
européennes
et donc je pense que c'est le bon
échelon pour peu qu'on ait effectivement
une intercommunalité intégré qu'elle ait
une cohérence territoriale parce que
c'est vrai que dans la loi note ya eu
parfois des fusions qui n'ont pas
toujours été réalisé avec en s'appuyant
sur un projet de territoire avec cette
définition de ce qu'on a en commun de ce
qu'on peut devenir ensemble etc
mais globalement je pense que c'est
c'est cet échelon pertinent et que quand
on a fait cette analyse quand on l'a
partagée quand on a un projet qui est
voilà qui réfléchit qui est fondée qui
on a des opportunités avec et c'est tout
le travail de jacqueline aujourd'hui
avec une probablement une relation
bloc local et à renouveler et même une
relation entre collectivités renouveler
et donc là on a beaucoup dit que par la
loi notre ont consacré le lien
intercommunalités région mon
développement économique etc ça s'entend
mais moi je constate aujourd'hui
dans la réalité qui est la mienne qu' il
ya un véritable axe aussi et c'est vrai
que c'est me vint très fort en lumière
aujourd'hui avec la crise sanitaire
entre les départements et les
intercommunalités les communes vals bloc
local pour voilà et donc je pense que si
on veut continuer si on veut pouvoir
réduire ses fractures il faudra aussi
qu'on réinvente on est en train de le
faire mais aller encore plus loin pour
garantir cet investissement public à
tout point de vue pas que dans les
infrastructures d'ailleurs mais aussi
sur un volet social très fort entre
l'état et et bloc local et entre le bloc
local et les collectivités supra
territoriales merci à nos on peut
l'applaudir et anne justement tu me
permet de faire le lien avec avec marc
fesneau puisque on a parlé de ce lien
entre le niveau local et le niveau
central le niveau de l'état marque
aujourd'hui est ce que tu ressens une
fracture entre les élus locaux et les
élus nationaux c'est vrai que on a
tendance à avoir ce débat entre paris et
la province
comment comment tu le ressens comment tu
le vis et comment vous travailler dessus
en tout cas pour améliorer la perception
oui à vendre bonjour à tous avant de
répondre à ta question je voulais juste
rebondir sur deux autres points si tu me
permets qui ont été évoqués le paradoxe
de ce que ce qu'a dit et frédéric sur la
question des gilets jaunes qui était un
mouvement fondé d'expression sur un
sujet à l'origine qui était plutôt de
taxes qui révélait tout le malaise
plutôt territoire ce que c'est plutôt
une crise territoriale qu'une crise d en
termes d'expression à ce chapitre qui
est pas de point d'ailleurs dans les
villes en tout cas l'expression s'est
fait sur les ronds-points devenue le
symbole des territoires abandonnés
je trouve que c'est intéressant parce
que
j'ai toujours considéré que c'était un
peu une injustice qu'ils étaient faites
parce que 2018 était plutôt le moment de
la fin d'un long cycle de d'abandon des
territoires que nous commencions à
essayer en fait on n'avait pas
complètement découvert pendant la crise
des gilet jaune la question des
amandiers territoire abandonné jeudi
sous l'oeil de jacques et parce qu' un
certain nombre d'initiatives qui avaient
été prises en termes de services publics
ce qu'avait dit à l'époque jean michel
blanquer autant me souvienne sur la
fermeture d'écoles
on avait déjà perçu ce sentiment
d'abandon des territoires et on était à
la fin d'un psy qui avait vu que ce
cumul est à la fois lentement mais assez
sûrement et fermement la disparition d'à
peu près tous les services publics
historique et emblématique des
territoires la poste trésor public
parfois les écoles globalement
deuxième point un sujet qui avait été
celui des dotations parce que quand même
ça c'était un peu ça c'était dans le
quinquennat précédent
troisième sujet qui avait été celui d'un
peut-être deux comment dirais-je de d'un
mouvement de désindustrialisation qui
s'est jamais interrompue entre les
années 70 milieu des années soixante dix
et 2018 alors que le discours du
président de la république est
nouvellement élu et menaceront était un
sujet déjà un discours de
réindustrialisation avec des mesures
plutôt favorable aux entreprises et
c'est très intéressant que ce cette
crise qui n'est qu'ils auraient dû
apparaître ya bien plus longtemps parce
que l'abandon et le sentiment d'abandon
des territoires il est très très très
très 13 pour l'avoir vécu tous les
épisodes du directeur de la poste qui
vient vous voir pour vous dire on n'a
pas grand monde va réduire les horaires
une deuxième fois pour lyon n'a toujours
pas grand monde évidemment comme il ya
moins d'horaires il ya maintenant et
puis après on vous dit bon ben
maintenant ces patients n'a pas fermé la
porte mais merci monsieur vous avez
tellement bien essayé de nous tuer qu'on
y est arrivé enfin je veux dire on a vu
le procès se met à l'oeuvre perçe on a
cru que c'était accepter c'était
complètement pas acceptée par les gens
plus un mécanisme qui avait fait que
quand même c'est grâce des responsables
sur coeur de ville petite ville de mâcon
a commencé tout d'un coup à se dire y
compris nous élus locaux la jemaye dans
la car des élus locaux que quand même
c'était pas mal d'avoir des commerces en
centre-ville et que le modèle périurbain
de grandes zones commerciales étaient
peut-être couillon mais c'était pas un
modèle de l'état st
pour certains il fallait avoir une rolex
quand vous voulez avoir réussi à 50 ans
pour d'autres il fallait voir son équipe
pour avoir réussi quand il était maire
non mais qui n'a pas son le caire où
sont ikea
et moi je me souviens m'être battue en
10 ans mais vous êtes sûrs qu'on va
accroître les mètres carrés comme ça ou
à l'habitant parce que les habitants
vont pas grandir et il va falloir qu'ils
bouffent
et qui boivent sinon on va avoir un
problème donc quand même et c'est tout
ce cycle là qui se termine avec la crise
des gilet jaune et qui avait déjà été en
brouille et je le dis parce que je pense
que c'est un quand même un sentiment qui
est important que les jo c'est que je
vais dire pardon que je vais répondre à
ta question
veissid pas être trop long
on a aussi rendu complètement illisibles
paysage institutionnel pour les gens
alors on est venu nous mêmes les élus
locaux et les élus nationaux de parfaits
techno qui parlons de truc que personne
ne comprend un
des pc a été les plh est
allé voir l'ami chu tout cas dans mon
village je sais pas de quoi on lui parle
il faut lui parler plus tôt d'autres
choses de d'habitat de logements de
transition écologique nous ont mêlé nous
mêmes élus sont tombés dans ce panneau
la plus on est tombé dans un deuxième
pas un troisième panneau qui était le
panneau dis toujours c'est les énarques
anti pas du tout les élus sont très
allants à l'idée de
jeudi toujours sans succès jacques il en
plaisantant caen et président de
communauté de communes on veut être
président d'agglo caen et président
d'agglo on veut être président de
communauté urbaine et puis quand même
quand on a réussi dans la vie on est
président de métropole et donc on a créé
22 métropole
pas pardon un
orléans et tours n'ont pas des sont pas
des métropoles pardon de même nature que
lyon et marseille
et donc on a fait peur aux gens avec
tout ça parce que on s'est dit mais
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est et ça ça
participe franchement des fractures
territoire sauf que la foudre est tombée
plus tôt ça m'amène à pau au sujet que
tu évoques elle est plutôt tombé sur le
niveau national alors que les le niveau
local est en grande partie responsable
de cette situation là nous sommes
collectivement responsables de la
situation d'abord non qu'on a créés dans
les territoires ça aussi poser un
problème qu'on l'a toujours pas résolu
ça fait lien d'ailleurs avec le côté
participation citoyenne c'est qu'on n'a
pas réussi à créer des espaces de
dialogue citoyen le dialogue de base il
était comme une
voie la grande ou petite d'ailleurs peu
importe il y avait quand même le maire
ses adjoints
le bon an mal an ça se discutait dans
cet espace là il n'y a pas d' espace de
dialogue et moi j'ai été président
d'interco et je suis comme un âne une
grande nef est un grand défenseur de
l'intercommunalité je sais le choix
français et les 36000 communes il faut
les garder et on les met en mode
coopératif parce que nous sommes dans un
week-end coopératif
et donc
je le dit à la blague mais j'aime
beaucoup le modèle à des communautés de
communes s'est on vient avec ce conte et
venez comme vous êtes comme disait
l'autre et et partageons essayons de
faire ensemble ce qu'on n'arrive plus à
faire tout seul il n'y a pas d' espace
de dialogue là dedans pour les citoyens
le jour je débattais aux journées
parlementaires du modem dans notre beau
département du loir-et-cher et
jacqueline avec le président de la
région
normandie
normandy oui tu te souviens et et nadia
je sais pas s'il a lui posé une question
parce qu'il disait le nouveau local ce
niveau du débat citoyen oui où est ce
qu'il le débat citoyen dans une grande
région puisqu'elle contre-pouvoir dans
une grande région
n'existe pas le contre-pouvoir dans une
grande région
or les citoyens ils ont besoin d'avoir
des pouvoirs des contres peut voir des
lieux des espaces séparés les césar sont
très utiles mais c'est pas un lieu de
débats et d espace citoyen c'est un lieu
de la société civile dit organisez kiss
qui parle et qui essaie de le bon c'est
bien les liens parfois malheureusement
de dépendance qui sont créées donc on a
vraiment besoin de créer 7
comment dirais-je une des fractures et
les liasses c'est qu'on n'a pas réussi à
créer des espaces et nous on a inventé
des espaces qui était plutôt dans le
registre de la rationalité l'efficacité
sauf qu'il ya un peu d'irrationalité
qu'il faut mettre et de passion parce
que sinon les gens ils vont mettre de
l'irrationalité ailleurs et le dernier
point sur cette fracture de tout ça
procède de la fracture nationale et
locale je pense qu'on a une
interrogation devant nous mais qui est
une interrogation comment dire
qui est lié au champ démocratique
c'est vrai que la fin du cumul ne voyait
pas en moi quelqu'un que j'étais plutôt
pour la fin du cumul
mais le cumul à fin du cumul n'a pas été
pensé dans comment ça s'organise et donc
maintenant vous avez des gens qui savent
qu'ils ne sont pas dans les mêmes
écosystèmes et qui chacun défende un
écosystème différents ce mandat là le
premier mandat sans cumul de mandats
c'est voter en 2016 c'est n'est
appliquée qu'en 2017 on verra les
conséquences de ces années c'est sur le
long terme parce que ce n est plus un
espace de dialogue se passe sujet d'être
député maire moi je crois pas qu'il
faille est maire pour comprendre la
réalité des gens ça c'est l'heure pour
le coup c'est un pipeau de nos
oppositions vous n'êtes pas tous mr
danse et ça je crois vous voyez à peu
près la réalité que vivent les gens
passent d'abord c'est la vôtre n'est pas
besoin d'être mère pour comprendre et
moi je peux le dire j'ai été maire dont
personne ne va me dire que
déterritorialisé métropolitain
métropolitain heureusement fausse pas le
sujet c'est pas ça le sujet c'est que le
sujet c'était que quand vous aviez des
gens qui avaient à moitié un pied
territoriales il ne jouait pas le niveau
local contre le niveau national or on a
construit là depuis quatre ans les
oppositions en construit trop souvent un
truc de c'est tellement mieux quand
c'est national et local et c'est
tellement dysfonctionnelle quand c'est
nationale site c'est confondant dridi
enfin pardon de ridicule parce que c'est
en train de nous une querelle une
fracture qui n'existe pas voyez bien que
le déploiement vaccinale moi quand j'ai
vu des présidents de région alors là je
décide pas pour être poli mais dire moi
je vais commenter du spoutnik bas
heureusement que non quoi
heureusement que ces commandes est
piloté quelque part parce qu'on se dit
danger quand même fin c'est j'aimerais
que des commissions d enquête pour
savoir où sont arrivés les masques qui
avait été commandée par milliards et qui
ont dû tomber de au pied de beaucoup de
camions sur les tarmacs de chine parce
qu'ils sont pas tous arrivés les masques
avec des gens qu'ils aient laissez moi
faire je suis compétent parce que les
ars ça marche pas oui ça reste sont pas
toujours formidable enfin et cette
espèce de culture qu'on a à qui on a
inculqué de faut laisser faire le local
parce que le national serait mauvais
mais c'est pas du tout comme ça il faut
que locales et nationales coopèrent là
aussi en de re coopérative on a vraiment
besoin de ça et on est un état qui n'est
pas un état construit par l'état il a
été construit par son centre et par son
centralisme pas la peine de le démolir
parce que si on ne démolit rien on n'est
pas dans le modèle espagnol et je joue
je croyais se croiser mon collègue
espagnol qui me disait vous êtes heureux
vous d'avoir alors voilà j'étais moins
d'accord d'avoir des parlementaires qui
sont quand même plus disciplinés que
chez nous parce que lui il a une
majorité un peu compliqué parce qu'ils
les relations avec le parlement aussi
aidé pour l'allergie style à gérer la
crise c'est quand même mieux parce que
vous avez vous décidé nationalement puis
vous déroulez passionnés que nous faut
négocier avec les régions si vous aviez
comme c'est cauchemardesque
et on l'a vu d'ailleurs sur la
différenciation parce que tout le monde
vend de la différenciation j'en parle
avec notre préfet je n'ai pas eu le
temps de te la raconter jacqueline et on
a vu quand on a dit bah on va faire la
différenciation en disant bas les
territoires qui ont beaucoup de taux
d'incidence l'an dernier on va ils
auront des mesures coercitives et puis
quand ils en auront pas on va fermer
sauf que c'est devenu paris contre
marseille
parce que pour manque de bol c'est tombé
sur marseille et les marseillais ont dit
c'est une mesure de coercition une
méchanceté de paris contre marseille
différenciation mal vécue parce qu'on
est aussi un pays qui qui veut de la
différenciation c'est pas le moindre des
paradoxes dans la relation nationale
locale mais qui veut que de l'égalité
et on l'a vu sur plein de sujets dans
cette crise cowitz et mieux vaut
emmerder tout le monde que de
différencier l'emmerdement parce qu'au
moins sept égalitaire où ça tout le
monde gueule
mais au moins c'est égalitaire et c'est
quand même un truc fou de dengue et donc
je pense qu'on a travaillé là dessus
dans un espèce de
faucon que que l'état central devienne
adulte et que l'état local vendetta le
les collectivités la puissance le calot
ci deviennent adultes n'est pas dans un
rapport de dominé dominant ou deux je
veux prendre ma place
et comme les régions pris beaucoup d
espace dans cette affaire là on a fait
des surpuissants locaux
et je finirai par un truc qui est assez
fascinant quand il ya un problème local
le jour où vous trouverez une
manifestation dans un département douane
vous me le signaler
on est dans un pays
où vous avez un pointe de transport
scolaire vous allez manifester chez le
préfet mais enfin le pauvre préfet et
n'a rien fait il est plus compétent en
termes de d'action je veux dire vous
allez à marseille vous fait engueuler
par les gens pour qu'ils commencent à le
milliard qu'on met sur les écoles et ce
pardon hein c'est la collectivité que
red bull m
donc ce n'est pas un dysfonctionnement
local ça il n'ya pas d'être parfait au
niveau local et un pare-feu niveau
national et d un parfait pour tous et
des profs comment
c'était eric tu as raison jean louis tu
as raison de me reprendre donc je jouais
ce que je veux dire il faut qu'on il
faut qu'on soit un peu adulte dans notre
mode de fonctionnement c'est ce que je
voulais dire dans le doigt dans le
rapport et puis un défi je trouve qu'il
faudrait analyser la situation je trouve
c'est assez fascinant ce qui se passe
sur les éoliennes
c'est une forme de fracture qui n'est
hors auto nettement des trucs plus moche
que les éoliennes on nous en a fait dans
les dernières décennies je veux dire
quand vous et des lignes à haute tension
des centrales nucléaires joue enfin j'ai
pas trouvé qu'en termes d'esthétique
c'était formidable donc faut pas dire le
poids n'est pas seulement l'éolienne le
problème c'est la l'implantation
d'infrastructures qui sont vécues dans
les territoires comme une violence qui
leur est faite de leur identité de leur
paysage et le fait qu'ils soient à eux
porter la charge pour les autres la
charge de ce qu'il faut faire en termes
de transition écologique faut vraiment
qu'on travaille là-dessus parce qu'on a
devant nous un assez gros problème je
rencontrais au moment des régionales un
collectif anti éoliens parce que ça ça
fleurit pas qu'au printemps d'ailleurs
c'est embrouillé aulas sait même plus en
beauce était partout mais c'est embêtant
bosses tu as raison c'est un rappel des
souvenirs et briser ce qu'il faut en
fait c'est il faisait la promotion du
nucléaire vous savez que dans cette
maison et françois l'a fait à plusieurs
reprises on pense que nous le nucléaire
c'est une loi et on ne dit pas abba
bourillon fait pas semblant se cache pas
derrière les murs on pense que c'est une
des voies avec la potentialité les
risques enfin c'est une des voies et
j'aurais dit bonne nouvelle vous n'allez
pas avoir d owlient par contre on va
vous installer une centrale nucléaire
croyez pas qu'on aurait un problème
aussi dire je pense qu'on serait dans la
même difficulté aujourd'hui d'implanter
des centrales nucléaires que d'implanter
des éoliennes
donc on a un sujet de débat parce que ça
aussi c'est vécu comme et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut faire gaffe
l'état central vient apposer à nos à
nous pauvres gens qui nous vivons comme
des mets prisé des infrastructures dont
on ne veut pas et là il faut qu'on mette
en place des processus de dialogue
auprès de participation très aboutie qui
permettent aux gens de s'approprier les
sujets sinon on fera plus rien parce
qu'on sera foutue d'implanter la moindre
installation là on est sur des sujets un
peu sensible mais ça peut être pareil
pour des questions d'entreprise ou d'un
ou des usines et donc on a un travail là
pour le coup
et là on a besoin aussi les
collectivités pas manger était trop long
mais j'avais plein de choses à vous dire
que vous avez vu merci beaucoup m
alors madame la ministre cheikh
jacqueline quand on entend ce qu'on
vient d'entendre tant le bilan que le
vécu qu'on a et le ressenti que nous
pouvons tous avoir de ses fractures
territoriales on voit que le travail est
immense
frédéric c'est très impressionnant
frédéric dole a rappelé ou même bosco le
sentiment d'absence de service public
l'accès à l'emploi les soins
on est à l'heure des transitions comment
et conduit l'action du gouvernement il
ya beaucoup de choses qui se sont faits
ces dernières années notamment sous son
autorité
beaucoup beaucoup d'actions concrètes
qui sont menées et comment vous arrivez
articulé avec les collectivités
alors d'abord je vais réagir par rapport
aux interventions qui ont été qui m'ont
précédé
souvent on a parlé de sentiments
sentiment de fractures sentiment
d'isolement sentiments et c est au fond
la première question qui se pose c'est
quelle est
quelle est la réalité le sentiment c'est
comment ça se se pose alors il ya des
gens effectivement qui qui se sentent
loin de tout qui se sentent en bas de
l'échelle il ya des inégalités en france
tout le monde le sait mais
et ça a été dit aussi c'est anne qui l'a
dit tout à l'heure nous sommes dans un
des pays les plus
redistributif au monde et ça
comme nous sommes des français que nous
aimons le débat politique
je crois que nous ne sommes nous ne
sommes pas capables de le rappeler
régulièrement nous ne nous faisons pas
nous nous enfonçons dans des discours
politiques d'opposition entre l'état et
les régions l'état et les collectivités
territoriales et caetera et caetera et
c'est laurent davezies dans son dernier
bouquin qui montre sa qui montre que
nous sommes vraiment dans un état où il
y à une redistribution très très
importante ensuite je voulais bien sûr
dire que c'est vrai que les français
sont très attachés au sentiment
d'égalité et vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure et au rôle de l'état qui doit
remplir cette mission et en même temps
ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
bosco vous avez décrit de façon
bucolique la france avec ses paysages et
caetera et nous avec marc on vous
écoutait parce que nous on est dans un
département
qui au fond la résultante
debout deux régions ancien ou de
province ancien avec eux au nord le
perche la beauce la sologne au sud est
c'est bon on connaît ça par coeur et
c'est vous rappelez
fernand braudel qui a le mieux décrit
tout cela en disant que la france se
nomme diversité et là où je suis je peux
vous dire que c'est au fond la france se
situe sur une ligne de crête entre ce
souci du rôle de l'état des l'égalité
etc et de l'autre côté des libertés
locales de la respect du respect des
traditions locales de la culture locale
et eux
qui conduit souvent à opposer les
collectivités territoriales et l'état
alors qu'on sait très bien mark l'a dit
parfaitement
pour pratiquer depuis quatre ans cette
fonction de ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
on sait qu'on est efficace que si il y a
un rôle conjointe de l'état et des
collectivités territoriales et bien sûr
spécifiquement où ça va le moins bien
parce que l'état joue son rôle justement
de comment dire de remise à niveau des
territoires qui sont les plus en
difficulté mais par populisme part je
fais un peu de politique mais par ouï
par populisme par volonté de s'opposer
au gouvernement et cetera il y à
vraiment des hommes politiques qui les
femmes bien sûr qui aggrave en
permanence le débat et cette notion de
fracturer d'archipel d'ailleurs je dois
vous dire que moi je n'utilise plus
c'est ces mots je n'ai je n'utilise plus
ses mots non pas que je nie jeu ni les
inégalités sociales qui peuvent exister
enfin je veux dire quand on connaît les
quartiers de certaines banlieues etc on
va pas dire ça n'existe pas mais je
pense que de l'utilisation de ces mots
en soit dans le débat politique en
toujours tirant vers le bas est quelque
chose qui ne fait qu'accroître le
malaise des français et non pas je
dirais le tirer vers le haut en
apportant des solutions
concrètes et donc je crois que c'est en
fait une mission compliquée mais qu'il
faut poursuivre de faire en sorte que
l'état et les collectivités travaillent
ensemble alors il ya il ya plusieurs
méthodes on a connu des périodes comme
après guerre où il y avait des plans qui
il y avait eu la destruction de la
france il y avait une nécessité de
reconstruire la france est au fond on
faisait
dans toutes les territoires français des
politiques un peu similaire dans la
notion de plan c'est ça qu'il y avait
dans la tête et puis il y a des périodes
qu'au moment où il faut recoudre un
certain nombre de territoires quand on
est dans le jeu parlant le bassin minier
du nord et de l'est on sait qu'il y à
des remèdes particulier qu'il faut
apporter et c'est pour ça moi
personnellement que je crois beaucoup
à la politique de contractualisation qui
permet à l'état de jouer son rôle c'est
à dire un rôle d' équité j'aime mieux le
mot équité qu'égalité un mot d'équité
entre territoires et entre les citoyens
et je crois que c'est quelque chose qui
répond à l'attenté de nos concitoyens
mais c'est vrai aussi par exemple quand
on fait des contrats avec les régions
qu'on appelle des contrats de plan état
région bas je pensais tout à l'heure au
président de la normandie que tu as cité
c'est en effet le dernier avec qui je
n'ai pas signé de contrat de plan état
région pour l'instant
mais ils ont des préoccupations aussi
pour combler certains retards dans
certaines régions
et il faut que l'état compense ces
retards mais il faut aussi parler des
ressources de l'état et des ressources
des collectivités territoriales parce
que le nerf de la guerre aussi c'est
souvent ça et alors je suis frappé aussi
souvent comment les les collectivités
sont attachés
à aux impôts traditionnelle vous savez
ce qu'on appelait les impôts locaux avec
pouvoir de taux et en assiette sur les
territoires c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
inégal
qui créent les plus grandes inégalités
en france et c'est pourtant à cela que
les élus locaux sont le plus attachés à
ce camp vous êtes maire de saint laurent
des eaux
en loir et cher ou d'avoine en indre et
loire vous avez une centrale nucléaire
sur votre territoire vous êtes les rois
du pétrole si je puis dire et c'est la
raison pour laquelle aussi les
politiques et tous les gouvernements ont
essayé de répondre aussi à une meilleure
péréquation à une meilleure
redistribution
sur les territoires et c'est la raison
pour laquelle par exemple la différence
entre les régions s'est amoindrie et on
le sait frédéric depuis que les régions
sur sur le partage d'un impôt national
c'est-à-dire la tva alors ça n'est pas
comment dire suffisant totalement mais
n'empêche que les écarts de ressources
entre les régions se sont amoindries
parce que on est plus sur un prélèvement
locales en fonction de la richesse et de
l'industrie locale et donc il y a
nécessité de travailler sur les leviers
de ressources aussi sur les territoires
pour que le partage à l'intérieur des
collectivités se fasse je prends les
départements de france qui
sont assez raisonnables parce qu'ils ont
mis en place un e mail à l'intérieur des
départements une péréquation qui ne se
partagent
sur l'ensemble du territoire et puis
bien évidemment
la richesse ce sont comment dire sont
différentes aussi selon le
positionnement des territoires et
l'organisation des territoires vous avez
fait tous appellent à la loi notre et
peut-être aussi à la l'autre loi qui a
redécoupé les régions et qui ont fait
apparaître de grandes régions et qu'ils
ont fait c'est le même gouvernement qui
a créé les grandes régions et qui
voulait couper la tête au département et
qui en fait à renforcer les départements
sur les territoires en créant cette ces
grandes régions et là aussi je pense que
la structure des collectivités
territoriales quand elles sont trop
grandes
joue un rôle assez négatif sur la
conscience politique de nos concitoyens
il est certain que entre la creuse et
les pyrénées atlantiques je fais ça au
hasard dans une même région la nouvelle
acte qui tu n le sentiment
d'appartenance à une
à un ensemble et tout à fait éloigner et
donc finalement c'est encore le fait
d'être dans une nation dans un état
français que les français se retourne se
retrouve le mieux il y avait aussi ce
que vous avez appelé la différenciation
alors c'est très les sentiments sont
très partagés on en parle souvent avec
marc
moi je dis que la différenciation peut
marcher comme je l'expliquais tout à
l'heure dans le sens où on a besoin
d'amener des outils des recettes des
financements différents selon les
régions
parce que le rôle de l'état c'est de
hisser de mettre fin aux fractures comme
vous dites
mais il y a aussi des cultures puisque
je suis en bretagne je vais le dire
comme ça je les cultures différentes
tous les
candidats
aux élections régionales en bretagne
tous les candidats avaient 1 une idée en
commun
je vais lancer un ballon cette idée
c'était de ne faire qu'une collectivité
rassemblant
les départements et la région
et la question c'est est ce qu'on peut
imaginer qu'on fasse ça dans certaines
régions et pas dans d'autres
c'est une question que je pose est ce
que c'est une la différenciation qui
répond à une attente locale mais est ce
que cette différenciation qui répond à
une attente locale parce qu'il ya un
fort sentiment d'être
breton qu'on soit dans les côtes d'armor
dans le finistère où dans le morbihan
encore que j'ai entendu ce matin le
président ferrand a dit qu'il était très
content dans un dette dans un
département
à savoir le morbihan qui était la
banlieue du finistère donc vous voyez
que même en bretagne on peut
trouver des sentiments quelquefois entre
ceux qui seraient les vrais breton et
des autres un peu moins et
en tout cas je me pose la question et je
suis prudente 1 quand je dis cela pour
savoir si au fond ce sentiment de
fractures que vous avez évoquées
et bien ou d'inégalités
ne peut pas vous peut se s'accentuer si
l'organisation française est différente
ou au contraire si elle va apaiser
comment dire le climat
social ou revendicatif qu'on peut
trouver dans certaines régions c'est une
question que je pose devant tout le
monde mais en tout cas je vais conclure
parce que j'ai été beaucoup trop longue
pour vous dire que moi je suis convaincu
convaincu que la france a besoin
ou plutôt les français ont besoin
de responsables nationaux et de
responsables locaux qui travaillent
ensemble et que tous ceux qui font
commerce en permanence d'opposer les
collectivités territoriales au à l'état
sont des gens qui
comment dire qu'ils sont des dangers
publics moi je le dis parce que je le
pense vraiment ce sont des dangers
publics qui mène au populisme que qui se
développe beaucoup en france et je crois
que nous avons à lutter contre cet état
d'esprit et tout à l'heure en main que
j'ai pensé quand tu disais c'est pas
parce qu'on est maire qu'on comprend
tout le citoyen comprend bien ce qui se
passait là oui ville comprend bien ce
qui se passe le procès d'intention qu'on
a fait au président de la république
quand il est arrivé parce qu'il n'avait
pas été élu local non mais c'est un truc
qui est invraisemblable et aucun
journaliste n'a jeu n'a jamais rappelé
que pompidou est arrivé sans avoir été
élu local qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire comme c est de gaulle en plus
voilà
et et voilà et c'est très intéressant
parce qu'au fond les opposants ont
construit
une fable n'est ce pas comme quoi en
fait on ne pouvait pas gouverner un pays
si on n'avait pas été élu local c'est
indécent c'est comme si
on ne pouvait pas être mère si on
n'avait pas fait je ne sais quoi avant
voilà merci merci jacqueline
alors avant de passer un temps d'échangé
avec vous et qu'on puisse poser des
questions aux intervenants frédéric
boulet ou les rebondir oui je voulais
dire deux choses c'est absolument
passionnant ce qui vient d'être dit la
part des ministres et ce qui était dit
bien sûr notamment mais il ya deux
choses qui marquent c'est d'abord ce que
dit jacqueline gourault est ce qu a dit
aussi marc fesneau c'est la faire
coïncider la réalité et la perception la
réalité soyons modestes sont utiles
sondages je crois que ça reste un outil
qui permet de bien connaître une réalité
plus qu'un réseau social puisque une
conversation dans un bistrot moins qu'un
tour de france de 5000 kilomètres mais
ça permet de connaître une certaine
réalité et le rôle du politique c'est
peut-être lorsqu'il a réussi c'est faire
coïncider cette réalité et cette
perception de la réalité je vous donner
quelques exemples sur cette concurrence
territoriale qui a été fait évoquer sur
cette bataille d'hernani le local ne
ment pas comme on disait jadis dans des
triste période la terre ne ment pas
versus le national a tout faux ce qui
est intéressant c'est que les français
vont quand même au delà de ça c'est vrai
que il faut le dire ça fait maintenant
quelques iec environ quelques années
quand dans des sondages un peu
artificiel aux demandes r&d pour vous
l'échelon local de trop il ya encore
quelques années c'était selon la
question le département ou la région
jamais jamais l'état bien sûr et jamais
l'échelon municipal jamais parce que oui
c'est l'échelon de troc de proximité et
plus une institution territoriale et
proche plus il ya de depuis y agirait du
répondant et plus on vote la corse enfin
pourrait-on parler il ya eu une
abstention beaucoup plus faible nous
présente la semaine prochaine à
montpellier une enquête pour la greffe
pour la congrès des régions de france on
voit très bien que il ya des raisons de
vote en corse qui s'est su très bien par
l'attachement au thé au territoire
considéré il ya quelques années c'était
une sorte de concurrence département
région ça fait maintenant deux trois ans
c'est vrai il faut le dire que c'est
systématiquement
dès le département qui est vu comme
l'échelon de trop alors parce que ces
régions apparaissent même en dépit d'un
déficit de proximité qu'on a vu dans nos
élections régionales dans le livre je
montre que 84 % des 18-24 ans n'ont pas
voté aux élections locales alors que
l'abstention automatique et massif des
jeunes n'est pas quelque chose d'écrit
ils ont parfois voter plus que la
moyenne à l'élection présidentielle en
80 ans 95 en 2007 c'était bien sûr des
élections de renouvellement de rupture
ça peut être moins le cas pour 2022
parenthèse fermée mais quand même on a
l'idée que la région a comme les villes
aussi on fait le job pendant la crise du
coc vite qui n'a rien créé mais qui a
amplifié ses tendances mais dans
d'autres enquêtes quand on sort de kehl
et les jetons de trop mais qu'on
demande quel est le schéma idéal pour
une politique publique locale réussie
c'est systématiquement ce que disait
goethe une grosse c'est à dire un
travail commun entre l'état la colite et
une colique 6e et une ou plusieurs
collectivités territoriales on n'est pas
en italie on n'est pas en espagne on est
en france et c'est vrai que heureux
relisons la dynamique de l'occident
c'est norbert elias si je me trompe pas
peut-être que je me trompe mais voilà
c'est quelque chose c'est un fait
historique majeur maintenant la
perception quand on interroge les
français si on qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que quand on part d'une france
télé c'est une france abandonné une
france à deux vitesses on pense à quelle
france jusqu'en 2005 2006 2005 la crise
des banlieues on nous c'était
systématiquement la france des banlieues
depuis 2008 2010 c'est la france rurale
est au contraire dans d'autres types de
questions quand on demande qu'il est
l'endroit en france où il ya le plus de
justice ils répondent les banlieues
alors que on devrait dire injustices
dans ce pays passionné par les
injustices ça vient de la jeunesse qui
parfois peut sombrer dans une forme deux
homos qui sait pas c'est pas notre débat
du jour on aurait pu croire injustice il
faut mettre le paquet sur la banlieue
mais justement la crise du résultat est
là les français ont le sentiment à tort
ou à raison que malgré
les sommes versées la situation ne
s'améliore pas qu'on est sur un enjeu à
venir en terme de traitement et de
résolution finale et donc on se tourne
davantage sur une france délaissé sur la
france des villes moyennes dans un
contexte je lisais également
d'attractivité à des gardes civils et
surtout des communes rurales et le but
pour le politique c'est peut-être voilà
montré que le résultat est là pour faire
court je dirais faire coïncider ces
différentes perceptions même si frédéric
un temps des échanges avec nos invités
bonjour
voila je suis le premier handicapé
physique à avoir été élue membre d'à
enfin président d'un conseil citoyen
chargé de l'urbanisme dans la banlieue
de laxou en meurthe-et-moselle où
j'étais où j'ai été président pendant
plus de 20 ans
je voudrais dire aux élus s'il vous
plaît
n'oubliez pas que c'est des citoyens qui
moi bon j'ai eu de la chance j'ai fait
j'ai fait des études de géographie
d'urbanisme et d'histoire donc j'ai eu
de la chance je comprenais le jargon qui
etc et que les élus utilisé mais sinon
un mec lambda enfin une personne lambda
pardon excusez moi
ne ne peut pas ne peut pas comprendre le
jargon au bout si au bout de six mois
six mois ça fait long et une deuxième
chose que je voudrais ce que je voudrais
dire je voudrais que vous réforme y est
le statut des élus handicapés s'il vous
plaît on va vous essayez de le réformer
parce que moi j'ai été obligé de refuser
un poste de d'adjoint la mairie de laxou
à cause de mon âge
sothema mon indemnité d'élue et est de
2200 euros et e qui dit et qui dit et
lui qui dit et lui veut veut qu'on veut
des places qu'on est des frais de
représentation et si j'avais accepté je
n'aurais pu quoi vivre merci beaucoup de
m'avoir écouté
on prend peut-être une série qu'on
reviendrait pans d'une série de
troisième au four madame oui
oui bonjour je voudrais vous étonner
voilà j'ai aujourd'hui 18 20 ans pour
ceux qui me connaissent c'est à peu près
mon âge je m'appelle ain où mohamed mais
j'habite du côté des volcans je prends
les volcans mais ça pourrait être
d'autre part alors là j'ai fait mes
études en me levant 5h30 du matin pour
aller à l'école un petit peu plus loin
puisque mon écoles étaient fermées je
rentrais il était 5h 5h30 pas le temps
de faire autre chose le mercredi dans la
famille le seul sport où on remet un peu
le cul des vaches et puis ça allait bien
et puis là j'ai quand même continué mes
études j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à suivre
internet parce que le cng elle n'existe
pas vous ou alors ça fait que 15 jours
parce que moi j étais la semaine
dernière il y en avait pas donc là je
dis bon bah je vais permet et une si je
fais mes études je vais pas avoir
d'argent regardez donc on peut me faire
un prêt étudiant mais le prêt étudiant
faut que mes parents puissent le
garantir bon bah je vais travailler je
trouve un travail bien chouette un
apprentissage bien chouette je vais
vouloir partir 150 ou 200 km de là ya
pas de moyen de locomotion alors je fais
un effort je dis je vais prendre un bain
blaquart et givet et là on me dit ben
oui vous avez un essai de 3 mois et
j'habite ou à il faut louer un lock il
faut louer un appartement bon si c'est à
paris on ajoute de 3000 euros pour avoir
trois mois de loyer devant et puis un
petit peu vous de quoi manger et après
on se demande on trouve pas de travail
donc ça peut-être que frédéric par
rapport parce qu'on parle de la jeunesse
qui aura peut-être des éléments à nous
apporter par rapport à l'étude que tu
que tu viens de livrer dans son ouvrage
la fracture une troisième question oui
voilà donc j'ai une question par rapport
au projet il ya des projets qui sont en
général mise en place et quelquefois il
met dix quinze vingt ans pour aboutir
est-ce que vous avez analyser pourquoi
ça met autant de temps même il s'agit
pas de les faire en trois mois mais il
faut réfléchir sur les processus qui
sont mises en place pour ces projets
puissent déboucher rapidement parce que
quelquefois quand on met dix quinze ans
le le le ce pourquoi le projet était
faux départ n'est plus valable donc je
crois qu'il faut réfléchir pour que sur
deux ou trois ans maximum tous ces
projets puissent déboucher c'est un
élément d'efficacité dans nos politiques
voilà
et d'autre part pour les collectivité
territoriale unique des possibles pour
c'est un autre élément d'analyser ce qui
s'est passé en martinique guyane corse
et mayotte puisqu'elle existe là-bas
alors c'est la première question
concernant le statut de l'élu des
personnes en situation d'handicap et
puis également notre jargon
qui voudrait
que j'ai entendu ce que vous avez dit en
fait vous avez expliqué que
vous perdiez votre allocation adulte
handicapé ou que vous dépassiez avec une
indemnité d'élu qui faisait que vous
perdiez alors je croyais que cette liste
cet avis a été réglé depuis trois ou
quatre ans mais je vais regarder ça de
plus près je vais voir ça avec amélie de
montchalin parce que je pensais qu'on
avait réussi j'avais eu ce cas en loir
et cher je m'étais occupé du maire de
lille je me souviens et je pense je
pensais que l'affairé était réglée mais
peut-être que ça ne l'est pas encore
puisque vous le vous le soulignez
je vais et je vous apporterai une
réponse précise
oui mais on n'a pas tout à fait ceux de
se raccroche
à législatif mais réglementaire
marque moi je voulais juste répondre le
jargon j'en ai parlé moi même je on
s'écoute un peu jargonner alors tout
toute corporation pour créer son jargon
quand je vois les agriculteurs jordi
vous avec personne comprend ce que vous
racontez 1 mais personne
et chaque structure créée saab sont
jargonne le monde de l'éducation le
monde de l'agriculture le monde des élus
le monde ministre sans doute sans doute
quand on y réfléchit bien le monde des
parlementaires fin bref donc on a besoin
de faire un effort parce que la
différence c'est qu'on est quand même
sur des sujets qui touchent au quotidien
des gens et que si on veut les embarquer
dans toutes les transitions qui sont à
l'oeuvre c'est important ça me permet de
répondre à la question de la temporalité
oui alors c'est vrai que les sur les
projets un certain nombre disent que ça
va trop lentement alors je pense qu'il
faut quand même qu'on distingue il ya
quelques projets parfois je me souviens
il sait pas si lointain quand j'étais
maire on aurait un tout petit peu
réfléchi on aurait il faut pas confirme
honte parfois vitesse et précipitation
de un projet qui met 20 ans
l'inquiétait pas très lointain là un peu
plus de 20 ans d'ailleurs en loire
atlantique je pense que c'est qu'il a un
problème le projet
quand mes 30 ans à faire sortir quelque
chose de terre ceux des études peuvent
durer mais vingt ans c'est long donc
c'est qu'on a un problème alors on a à
la fois besoin d'avoir une réflexion
assez long terme parce que je compte les
enjeux qu'on a devant nous qu'on fait
quand on fait l'urbanisme on a besoin de
vraiment penser à 20 ou 30 ans et de
déployer sur vingt ou trente ans son
urbanisation
au moins parfois
et en même temps on a besoin d'associer
à sa des projets concrets qui est soit
dans une temporalité
comment dirais-je bien plus courte au
cas la prospection l'aménagement qui
nécessite du temps long et puis les
projets qui nécessitent du temps court
mais du temps long sur un projet c'est
qu'un problème avec le projet pis
dernier point pour répondre à josette
qui a toujours 20 ans c'est que
ça permet dit ce que je voulais dire
tout à l'heure aux 6 et je trouve que le
cola coville locaux viennent enfin comme
on veut à
a complètement inversé le regard qu'ils
avaient sur les territoires dits peu
denses
je ne dis pas ruraux mais peu denses en
tout cas vous le sentiment que dans ce
territoire là on était d'une certaine
façon protégé qu'il y avait une forme de
proximité un peu imaginaire un conte et
au grand air que on pouvait faire des
circuits de proximité qu'on était
beaucoup plus maintenant ces termes à la
mode résilient dans la sphère de la
coved les territoires là ont une
capacité d'attraction aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs dans beaucoup de territoires
il y avait des sujets devant de deux
bien qu'il n'existe plus puisqu'ils ont
tous été vendus mais ça m'amène à ta
question parce que ça va amener un
deuxième sujet c'est qu'est ce qu'on
offre comme service pour que les gens il
n'est pas fait un aller et un retour
rapide sur une autre terre et ça c'est
la question de l'habitation la question
de la mobilité va être une question
absolument centrale ce qu'on fait sur la
le déploiement à la fois des réseaux
téléphoniques et et du haut débit c'est
absolument essentiel
et on a besoin de penser notre
aménagement du territoire pour faire en
sorte que des gens qui vont être très
attiré par ces territoires là les villes
moyennes les territoires plus ruraux ils
trouvent des solutions de mobilité pour
pas qu'ils ce que tu décris va c'est
juste que les jeunes qui s'y installent
il est qu'un choix dans leur vie c'est
soit pas faire d'études fait sortir du
territoire dont ils ont réussi sont les
enfants or les territoires ont besoin de
garder leurs enfants s'ils perdent leurs
enfants c'est quand même une partie de
la richesse d'un territoire et son
identité qui se perd donc on a ça a
travaillé avec arme un sujet qui tout ça
se fait dans un contexte de contraintes
et légitime d'ailleurs liées à la
transition
ou aux transitions qui sont devant nous
vous essayez de préserver le foncier
faut essayer de réduire nos gaz à effet
de serre donc on a besoin aussi de faire
ça à la fois donc c'est ça qu'il faut
qu'on essaie de combiner mais je pense
que c'est ça pour le coup c'est devant
nous mais on a à mon avis deux trois
quatre cinq ans pour ces territoires là
pour profiter du moment on dit après
tout l'exode urbain pourrait nous
avantageux nous avantager à ses puces a
puissamment me semble-t-il merci marc
alors oui masi
peut-être sur la complexité des sur le
sur le temps en fait des projets on a
dix ans et c'est alors je rejoins ce que
dit marc parce qu'on a besoin de cette
visibilité et qu'un aménagement du
territoire il peut pas penser parce ceux
pensés pour juste le mandat en fait il
nous engage surplus du plus long terme
en revanche il faut quand même
reconnaître que parfois on a des
dispositifs qui sont d'une complexité
folle et qu'on a besoin de
simplification et que le temps des élus
n'est pas le temps des citoyens et que
le temps de l'administration n'est pas
le temps des élus non plus donc chacun
doit avoir prendre sa part de
responsabilité
voilà les élus doivent les élus doivent
être raisonnables dans leur
communication parfois on communique trop
tôt je pense les citoyens doivent
pouvoir participer à la décision et
c'est enfin
en tout cas ils doivent comprendre ce
qui est en train de se jouer mais il ya
aussi des niveaux où on doit simplifier
la mise j'ai une pensée pour deux choses
on a parlé de notre modèle de
redistribution n'a pas parlé des fonds
structurels européens qui sont
extrêmement puissants dans notre pays
qui permettent de résorber ces
inégalités mais qui sont finalement
sous-employés parce que trop complexe et
l'état français et c'est pas la faute de
l'europe nécessairement mais l'état
français et on met ça coulait et puis
après tout les niveaux intermédiaires on
peut parler des autorités de gestion que
sont les régions là on a un besoin
criant de simplification pour aller
chercher cette finance ses finances la
et puis j'ai en tête aussi l'anru voilà
l'anru c'est quand même un pour ceux qui
sont dans ces quartiers-là monter un
projet en rue oui alors pardon agence
nationale pour la rénovation urbaine
donc est dédiée ou au quartier hyper
dense on concentre
voilà c'est c'est oui je vais faire des
efforts c'est premier monsieur ministre
mais voilà c est hélas les cantons
démarrer qu'on commence à dire on a
réussi à remporter voilà on est inscrit
dans la rue donc voilà avec les élus
locaux cris cocorico parce que c'est
parfois aller chercher le couteau entre
les dents mais donc du coup le en fait
on n'y est pas encore aux premiers coups
de pioche est donc le temps passe et les
citoyens ne comprennent pas et donc je
rejoins marque quand il dit qu'on a
besoin d' espace de dialogue abouti
urgemment en fait parce que ça permet de
partager cette information et ça permet
même de évidemment construire certains
projets sur le lac est ce le les
l'histoire cataclysmiques que vous venez
de nous raconterez non mais je ne dis
pas qu'il n'existe pas je ne dis pas
qu'il n'existe pas je dis qu'il est
quand même assez rarement qu'enfin il me
semble assez rarement cataclysmique d'un
bout à l'autre de ce que vous nous avez
raconté et qu'en tout cas je je je pense
que il ya bon nombre de territoires pas
partout parce qu'ils sont pas intégrés
de la même manière ils se sont pas dotés
tout toujours des compétences ils ont
pas toujours la volonté politique au
sein de leurs terres de leur projet de
territoire mais c'est quand même assez
rarement aussi catastrophique que ça il
ya un nombre de dispositifs qui existent
et qui parfois même sans pile dans l'est
dans nos territoires alors évidemment
prêt faudrait préciser les territoires
et il ya deux choses là dedans qui nous
viennent à l'esprit dans ce que vous
racontez il ya l'accès au droit et pas
seulement le droit avec un grand démêler
droit à l'accès
et la communication il est pour beaucoup
il ya des choses qui sont finalement
très accessible quand on les regarde
objectivement mais que nos concitoyens
ne mobilise pas pourquoi ils ne les
mobilise pas c'est ça la question en
fait qu'est-ce qu'on a ratés en termes
de communication j'ai sur mon territoire
une plateforme de la mobilité il n'est
pas possible en scène heures cent cinq
mille habitants un axe structurant avec
un transport urbain qui voilà qui est
bien présent mais des zones rurales où
il y en a pas parce qu'évidemment on n'a
pas les sous pour pouvoir irriguer
l'ensemble du territoire mais j'ai une
plateforme de la mobilité qui nous coûte
un bras qui avec les cofinancements de
l'état 2
qui apporte une solution je vous assure
qu'il ya une solution pour toutes les
personnes jeunes moins jeunes personnes
handicapées en est pour toutes les
situations en insertion professionnelle
en besoin de soins etc j'ai trop peu de
personnes qui mobilise encore ça donc on
a on a nous des efforts à faire en terme
de communication il ya des relais qui ne
se font pas bien bon là on est on est
même dans la coopération intra
territoriale avec les associations
porteuses etc il ya cette question me
semble-t-il d'accès au droit et puis
cette lisibilité des dispositifs
auxquels il faut qu'on fasse attention
merci anne je voulais peut-être que
frédéric réagissent par rapport aux
propos de madame concernant concernant
la jeunesse puisque l'étude ifop qui a
été éconduite donc cette étude dite
nouvelle vague
et qui relatait dans son ouvrage la
fracture illustre justement la
perception qu'ont les jeunes aujourd'hui
de la société donc à la fois tu va le
développer une société qui est pas des
jeunes qui sont résilients mais qu'en
même temps de moins en moins confiance
dans nos institutions
et qui en même temps se retourne vers
des valeurs dites plus traditionnelle
ça me permet de rebondir sur la question
qui a été posée oui il ya des jeunes
font de plus en plus leur marché entre
des valeurs traditionnelles et des
valeurs plus si je puis dire moderne
savait que jamais et la référence la
première enquête fait en 1957 à partir
de laquelle françoise giroud forge de
concept de nouvelle vague et cette
enquête a été renouvelée tous les
poulets dix ans il a été réactivé
spécialement pour ce livre 21 ans après
la dernière jamais la valeur travail a
été autant
valoriser en termes
d'émancipation en terme de réussite de
sa vie personnelle des ruptures convoi
dans la genèse par rapport au passé
c'est nous qu'on a connu dans les années
80-90 c'est-à-dire l'envi la tentation
de créer une sorte d' étanchéité absolue
entre sphère personnelle et sphère
professionnelle ça va ça vole en éclat
du côté de la jeunesse alors pour
revenir plus sur la sur la question sur
la question du travail et de l'accès à
l'emploi la jeunesse n'est bien sûr pas
un bloc monolithique les plus jeunes et
malgré la crise du coc vide et c'est là
que tu reprends ce terme de résilience
qui est bien sûr un petit peu galvaudé
ont été bien sûr touché mais puisqu'ils
ont tous vécu des représentations faites
commune il ya une sorte de conscience
générationnel un peu comme l'épreuve du
feu en 14 toutes proportions gardées
c'est à dire qu'ils ont eu le sentiment
d'avoir perdu leur temps de devoir payer
pour la dette est entre parenthèses et
c'est bien de le dire dans le cadre du
parti de françois bayrou qui le premier
de manière assez massive en 2007 a remis
la dette au coeur du débat présidentiel
mes amis pour 2022 7 cette thématique
n'est même plus citées par les français
et est très pris et très peu pris en
charge par le monde politique alors que
les jeunes en parlent et donc cette
conscience générationnel fait de toute
une série de perception n'a été
sacrifiés on a été stigmatisé n'empêche
pas les plus jeunes de se projeter très
positivement vers vers l'avenir et de
survaloriser la valeur travail ça c'est
chez les plus jeunes mais chez les 25 30
la génération de l'inter 2-1 de
l'insertion qui malgré la crise qui est
pas ce wiki ils entendent aussi la
question des emplois non pourvus donc il
ya aussi une des véritables tensions et
jamais le discours sur l'assistanat
c'est à dire les chômeurs pourraient
trouver du travail s'il le voudrait qui
avant étaient cantonnés à la droite de
la droite puis la droite républicaine
qui maintenant arrive à gauche n'a été
autant mobilisés par les jeunes donc
cette génération de l'insertion a
beaucoup moins confiance et beaucoup
plus inquiètes et politiquement et
électoralement ça se traduit par une
jeunesse de moins cinq ans qui est très
favorable au président macron parce
qu'on a le sentiment qu'il agit qui
bouscule les codes qu'il s'inscrit en
distinction avec ses différents
processeurs et en revanche les 25 30 ans
sont nettement plus favorables à un vote
tribunicien il s'appelle le pen eric z
ou je ne sais pas qui etc j'ai pas donné
de nom et
au moins ça reste confidentiel et c'est
quelque chose qui m'a absolument frappé
ces jeunes de 25 30 ans sont quasiment
trois quarts à dire en période de crise
il faut réserver
les emplois en priorité aux français ces
jeunes qui n'ont pas connu je marie le
pen père reprenne s'en sort gêne si je
si je puis dire le la le principe
historique du front national lorsque
jean marie le pen a déboulé dans au
début des années 80
bien merci frédéric 1
une autre question 3 3 pieds de question
qu'un qui après on passera là à la table
ronde prochaine
madame oui je suis étonné qu'on pende
n'ai pas parlé des maisons france
services qui sont quand même un
excellent moyen de revitaliser nos
territoires et de répondre à tous et
gilet jaune qui se sentait vraiment
abandonné et je pense que c'est un
retour vers eux qu'il faut non seulement
connaître nous déjà tous pour en parler
et puis les médias devraient leur
prendre parce que c'est vraiment quelque
chose que je trouve très positif
merci de nous
mettre au goût du jour
merci madame de de parler de de france
service
c'est vrai que au fond et tout à l'heure
frédéric parler de la crise sanitaire et
de la démographie médicale qui est un
sujet très important
pour les français et d'ailleurs il
englobe dans vos services publics la
notion médicale
aussi est ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
tout ça a été une lente décrue sur les
territoires depuis 30 ans pour des
raisons
de politique parfois comme pour la santé
comme quand même on a eu une politique
malthusienne total pour la formation des
médecins et je rappelle que c'est ce
gouvernement qui a levé le numerus
clausus alors bien sûr il faut le temps
de former une nouvelle génération de
médecins pour le voir même s'il ya des
solutions intermédiaires on pourrait
débattre sur le sujet et puis il ya les
services publics qui
ont reculait sur les territoires ont
reculé ou parfois je dois le dire comme
cela n'ont jamais existé et france
service est effectivement quelque chose
de très intéressant parce que en fait
dans ces maisons c'est un point unique
où l'on retrouve au moins neuf services
publics que ça soit le service des
impôts l'a aimé ça la retraite pour
l'emploi et caetera et en fait les
français sont très sensibles à ce
développement défendre services qu'ils
ont l'impression ils ont pas que
l'impression il voit revenir c'est là où
on voit la réalité il voit revenir sur
les territoires
et dans un lieu unique
des
maisons françaises vis et bien
évidemment c'est lié aussi et je dois le
dire on en a parlé tout à l'heure ses
marques au développement de la fibre sur
l'ensemble du territoire parce que vous
savez que francs services et des gens
physiquement qui répondent à des
questions de nos concitoyens mais il
peut y avoir aussi des systèmes de
relais par
visio par vidéo etc avec des services
qui sont à 20 ou 30 km et où on a une
réponse immédiate puisque on a des gens
désignés dans un service pour répondre
et cela c'est très important et je
voudrais insister non seulement sur les
maisons france et revit sans lors il y
en a mille 500 en france qui à ce jour
ont été créés dont 1000 dans la ruralité
donc je tiens à le préciser
avec bien sûr des partenaires que sont
les collectivités territoriales a aimé
ça et cetera la poste et je voudrais
bien sûr dire que il y a une autre chose
qui est très importante et je reviens un
peu sur les histoires de projet tout à
l'heure mais puisque je les micros gens
j'en profite
c'est aussi ce qui a été terrible sur
les territoires c'était le recul aussi
du service public au niveau de
l'ingénierie au niveau technique moi
j'ai été maire j'ai été élu maire en
1989 ce qui fait un certain nombre
d'années on avait dans les départements
dans les services techniques de la dde
comme on disait à l'époque des gens qui
accompagnaient les élus et qui
apportaient leur savoir leur technicité
leur matière grise et qui accompagne et
aussi les élus pour la réalisation de
leurs projets et vous savez qu'il y a eu
pendant des années un recul très
important c'est la dernière année et
surtout on a vécu une période où la mode
et ça a été dit tout à l'heure entre
guillemets
c'était le fait régional et on a coupé
la tête à peu près à 30 % des
fonctionnaires d'état dans les services
techniques des départements et ça ça a
joué au jeu j'en suis certaine au niveau
des collectivités territoriales et des
plus petites d'entre elles un rôle
désastreux et je pense n'est ce pas et
c'est la volonté du gouvernement
aujourd'hui le premier ministre et le
précédent premier ministre était sur la
même ligne d'ailleurs
rvr remettre sur les territoires au
niveau départemental plus de technicité
pour accompagner aussi les locaux c'est
aussi pour cela que nous avons créé
l'agencé nationale de cohésion des
territoires en faisant des préfets de
département
des représentants de cette agence
nationale de cohésion des territoires
avec des bons à tirer pour les élus et
gratuit dans les communes de moins de
3500 habitants pour tout problème
technique pour accompagner un projet
monsieur et ça je crois que c'est
extrêmement important le retour de la
vie dans et de l'activité dans la dans
les zones les plus rurales c'est quelque
chose évidemment de fondamental mais qui
doit vivre aussi avec son époque et
c'est pour ça n'est ce pas que le
développement de la fibre vous savez que
nous sommes le premier pays européen
pour le développement de la fibre et
c'est fondamental quand on pense que le
téléphone a mis 50 ans à
aller jusque dans le fin fond des
campagnes nous aurons fait pendant ce
quinquennat un bon absolument
extraordinaire et ça va rendre service
aussi à la télémédecine enfin tout ça
est dans tout si je puis dire
merci beaucoup jacqueline bien nous
appelons nous allons devoir terminer
cette table ronde merci à tous nos
intervenants pour votre présence et pour
la qualité de vos échanges et je vous
invite à rester sur la prochaine table
ronde est justement qui s'adresse à la
jeunesse également fait comment faire
reculer l'abstention aujourd'hui et
c'est un débat entre
les mouvements de jeunesse des
différentes formations politiques
françaises
[Musique]